you know acting you get there's no you
don't have to
recoup so I hear as long as I don't play
myself yeah as long as you don't play
it's crazy too cuz like uh for you like
I feel like we're in like a Renaissance
of like it used to be a thing where you
would describe an artist as like a
female rapper mhm but female rappers are
running rap yeah so Just Like Rappers
yeah yeah like it's like the best like
you know if you could like rewind like
2018 2017 it'd be like oh there's this
new female how many female rappers can
pop at the same time it was that
narrative cuz it was like just Nikki for
so long but now it's like I just wish
the dudes would care about making real
records like the women are these days I
think we we had our time like we we
deserve this time now it's been so many
years um since a all woman Dynamic was
dominating that's probably since like
like back in the day it was like the you
had like the brat Little Kim foxy Eve
like a lot of people doing their thing
at the same time I feel like now though
it's like way crazier yeah it is and
there's so many like spectrums like you
could get rap city was one of the
greatest period shout out to rap city
and then you got like sexy red who you
can you know for sure I love the
dichotomy between all of them no that's
I think it's dope Have you listened to
Andre 3000 flute album I can't wait to
listen to it I haven't sat down yet but
like that Andre somebody I'm an
Enthusiast of like I just feel like
whatever he drops I want to cons got
Outcast album right there
my that's like my third favorite album
of all time I love that I love Outcast
but no I I'm not going to lie I saw I
saw the press release and I was just so
[__] I was like yes yeah and then I read
and it was like there'll be no rapping
it's just the flute I said okay well at
least I'll have some music to trip on
shrooms too eat some shrooms get high
let Andre play the flute in the
background no and I like his self-
awareness in it too I feel like
evolution is so important for artists to
like understand what what what a lane of
Life they're in at the moment yeah like
did you saw what he said yeah he was
like I don't have nothing to rap about
so you want me to rap back get into
colonoscopy and I was like sure I
literally listen to you rap about
anything yeah yeah colonoscopies uh you
know IRAs whatever you want to rap about
but we're going to get the flute sounds
the flute I'm excited about that uh on
this new album you got a lot of dope
features amoretta who I think is really
dope and slept on yeah she's incredible
um who who's first of all what's your
favorite song on the album and for you
what was like the feature that meant the
most to get done for this one H that's a
good question um my favorite song
changes often but right now it's safety
net um it's the track of Brook Valentine
number 10 um and it's just very like
wait Brook Valentine is
that girl fight yeah girl fight yeah oh
wait she's married to my boy yeah yeah
so she's on a Virgo record because she's
married to a Virgo which is my brother
Marcus like love him your brother my bro
like my bro he's a great guy yeah he's
he's incredible he just hit me like a
month ago for and told me hey my wife do
you want to book her at cuz I have a
club in Scottdale and I was like you're
married to Brooke Valentine yes yeah I
just fig yeah shout out to Brook
Valentine girlfriend yeah okay shout out
to Marcus great guy great family yeah I
love like his like he just be giving
game away you say free game yeah for
sure I love it um but yeah that's like
one of my favorite on the project and
then my favorite person that have worked
with throughout it
um she I was happy to uh uh damn
everybody I really enjoy everybody was
there like a studio like what like were
cuz these days you might get a song sent
to you were you able to like get in I
sat down with everybody I flew into each
person's like Hometown or whatever and I
made an environment I would say I I did
safety net yeah yeah and act like you
know all in one session at west lake and
everybody was there everybody who was
featuring on it came into the studio and
we did it together was that the funnest
session it was the most uh productive
yeah creative yeah it was just it was
just really fun like to watch
everybody's like ideas ping off each
other and stuff like that was really
dope what is your uh pen game like are
you writing everything are you yeah are
you punching in like how do you no I'm
I'm one take lady like I'm literally I
don't punch often so you'll have you'll
have your [__] like look I'm I'm already
ready yeah or like I'll I'll write in
there if I'm like cuz like safet n for
example I wrote the whole record so
like I sat down and I can't sing so I'm
like girl like you know this what we
doing this what we doing we got to do
and so um she just man everybody did
their part on that you know how much
writing do you do for other people uh
not as much anymore I I kind of got my
start in songwriting at first so I used
to you know obviously be in writing
sessions and whatever whatever but
that's a that's a grind people don't
know man oh my God you might be in a
session and feel like we got one and
then it doesn't make the album yeah that
happens all the time and then the song's
just like
in I don't know and you don't know whose
hands they'll end up in like that's the
crazy part is knowing like you wrote it
for this person and then this person has
it now or you know or it comes out 5
years later and you're like yeah like
when you're a producer and a songwriter
it is a it is a It's a Grind man cuz cuz
those Studio sessions can be 8 10 12
hours and then you don't even know if
it's if you even got anything out of it
like right